hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about
mucor mycosis which is a fungal disease
prevalent in
immunocompromised individuals
such as people who are recovering from
kovid19
or people who are suffering from cancer
or hiv
so much or mycosis is a fungal disease
and it has taken the headline
of news these days it has created a huge
fury in everybody's mind so let us try
to understand
what is much or microsis what is the
biological basis of this infection
how we can prevent the infection and
what are the possible treatment option
so stay tuned till the end of this video
mucor mycosis which was previously known
as
zygomicosis is a serious but rare fungal
infection
which is caused by a group of moles
known as much or mice micros mucor
mycetes so these mucor mycetes
group encompasses rhizopus species
and mucour species which roughly look
like this they have a characteristic
shape now these moles
live throughout the environment they are
almost
everywhere we would learn in specific
region where they are present or where
they are abundant but the key picture
which is coming out
from the news headlines is it is
creating a huge swelling
and inflammation near the ocular area
and many people are losing their vision
due to these kind of infection
so let's try to understand the
pathophysiology of this disease
so first let's ask that how does this
infection happen
and where do you find these funguses
we can find mucourmicrosis in many
places
such as moist soil decaying organic
matter
animal dung leaves etc
all of these places you might find these
funguses now once you're passing through
this
area some of the fungal spores you might
accidentally unknowingly you might have
inhaled them
now in normal situation it's not a big
deal
our body knows how to fight against it
but it's a big deal
for people who are immunocompromised and
in a moment it would be clear
but before that let me tell you these
fungal infection
can happen via several routes one of the
common route is
entry via inhalation where the spores
enter our
lungs via our airways
right second there could be also entry
point
via a injury site let's say you have
injury in your hand
and these fungus spores might have
entered your system
via that or it could be taken inside
with food so there could be also gut
associated entry points
now any fungal disease can be classified
based on following criteria and it's
important to understand
the several classes of much or microsis
infection as well
so based on the site of infection we can
classify them as superficial
cutaneous subcutaneous deep or systemic
now based on root of accusation they
could be exogenous versus
endogenous and based on virulence they
could be primary or
opportunistic so these are different
classification modes
now let me tell you as far as this
mucormicosis infection is concerned
there are rhinoceros mycosis
which generally affects the sinus and
the brain
whose symptoms include one-sided facial
swelling
headache nasal congestion
jaw pain maybe fever etc
now there are other types such as
pulmonary mucous mycosis
whose symptoms include
fever cough severe chest pain shortness
of breathe
etc there are other types such as
cuteness
mucour mycosis where skin is getting
infected and there are patches blemishes
on site on the screen
there could be pain warmth excessive
redness
on those areas now in case of
gastrointestinal mucour mycosis there
could be severe abdominal
pain nausea and gastrointestinal
bleeding
all of these kind of infections are
possible
now the last type is disseminated
uh much or microsis now this typically
occurs in people who are suffering from
several diseases or several medical
conditions
or they are suffering from comorbidity
such as diabetes
so it's very difficult to track what is
the
cause of their bad health and this is
the
severe most case now these
fungi aren't really harmful to people
and our body learned that how we can
possibly deal with these fungi
problem occurs in immunocompromised
individuals
because their body don't know how to
really deal with it
and their immune system is now weakened
so this kind of infection is prevalent
in
patients who had undergone organ
transplantation
stem cell transplantation some kind of
injury
or people who are using
immunosuppressants for a long time such
as
corticosteroid usage for a long time
right
there could be also chances that people
who are
abusing drugs people who are taking
diabetic medications
people who are taking chemotherapy or
undergoing or fighting with cancer
they might also catch this infection
because their immune system is also
weakened
so it's kind of a secondary infection
that happens when your
immune system is really weak generally
the chances are
if you are having a very good immune
immune response and your immune system
is good
then you might not catch this infection
and even if you catch this infection
your body knows how to deal with it
for example specifically let's take the
example of
aids patient now aids patient
they have very low count of th helper
cells
and that is why they are more prone to
fungal infection now these kind of data
tells us that these th helper cells they
are really important to combat
fungal infection if you want to learn
detailed procedure by which our body
fight backs these kind of
fungal infection you can click on the i
button and the video would be there for
you
now the biggest question that we have in
our mind that
is much or micros is contagious as
contiguous as kovid19
and the answer is no it's not contagious
so the chances are you are not spreading
spreading it to an individual who is
near
you now the question is how we can
lower the risk of neocormicosis first of
all
we can possibly avoid places which are
dusty or which has all of cow dung or
other kind of like animal fish fishes
moist soil or places which are moist and
filled up with funguses
we can possibly avoid those places now
if that is not possible one way of
preventing or reducing the risk of
infection is using a n95 mask
and also maintaining good hand hygiene
is crucial for avoiding the infection
lastly what we can all do is get a
healthy meal
and eat those substances which can boost
our immune reaction
now this is an indirect way of fighting
back
because if we strengthen our immune
system
it might be more efficient in terms of
clearing fungal infection as well
and we have to avoid processed food as
much as possible because
they doesn't have they don't have a
nutritive values and they are not really
useful to boost our immunity
now let's try to understand how the
detection of mucour mycosis takes place
let's say you have a mucour microsis in
lung so it's a pulmonary
variant of that so you can possibly have
a biopsy
from your lung or if you have a sign
sinus
or cranial sinus a kind of mucus
microsis infection
you might have a sample from uh the
sinuses and lastly those samples are
sent to the lab
where culture experiments are performed
or using microscopy you can also
determine
whether this fungus has infected your
body or not
your doctor might also prescribe a ct
scan
in specific cases now let's try to
understand how our body
fight backs against funguses you know
the detailed video is given in the eye
button
there are several cell types in our body
which plays crucial role
in terms of fighting funguses one such
cell type
is neutrophil but before that let me
tell you
both our immune system that means the
inner immune system
and the adaptive immune system has the
capability of fighting funguses
immune innate immune cells such as
macrophages dendritic cells or
neutrophils can fight funguses
specifically th1 subtype of cell and
th17 type
of cell can fight back funguses
now phagocytosis by neutrophil is one of
the strong defense response
against the fungi and another
strong immune response against the fungi
is orchestrated by th1 subtype
which produce interferon gamma which is
a cytokine
and that is how it try to
cope up with the fungal infection now
interferon gamma activates macrophages
increase their phagocytotic capability
and this is how
our body fights back now th17 cell is
one of us
subtype of t helper cell which is
specialized for fighting against
fungal infections now these
th17 cells secrete one particular
molecule which is known as il-17
that is crucial to fight fungal
infections
it is found that when there is a fungal
infection
these th cells get differentiated to
this specific
subtype and this happens via specific
cytokine signaling but where does the
cytokine come from
these cytokine come from or secreted by
dendritic cell or macrophages when
dendritic cell and macrophage
sends the sense the presence of funguses
like mucour microsis they sends
a signal to these th cells and they
push them to get differentiated
or to become this specific subtype which
can
combat these fungal infections
but all of these mechanism fails
or these mechanisms are severely
compromised
in patients which are undergoing
aids hiv cancer or
people who are recovering for from kobe
19 whose immunity is very weak
so which i mean these increases
the chances of having these kind of
secondary
fungal infection now
let's understand that all of these
fungus species that we talked about
all of them are not bad after watching
this video if you think all of these
funguses are bad
it's not true there are millions of
fungal species
and about 400 to 500 are potential
disease-causing agent
so all of them are not bad indeed we eat
nice mushrooms
in our diet which is also very
beneficial for
us so in this situation
you have to understand what possibly
what medications can be prescribed
so to combat with fungal infection
doctors might prescribe antifungal
agents
and i'm not going to take any names for
them but in case of severe
infection surgical removal of the tissue
might be
useful and this is up to our responsible
health care workers doctors and nurses
they will assess the situation and do
whatever is necessary
so a huge respect to them i hope you
enjoyed this video and this video was
informative for you to understand the
concept
if you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to like share and
subscribe thank you and if you can
and possibly you can support me in
patreon
let this video be a fundraiser video all
the fun that this particular video would
raise
i would donate all of that in charity
with that
i'll say goodbye to you guys thanks for
listening